and rich hill
heads to the mound
rich hill so this be the eighth start
for hill 1-1 5.17 but he's been much
better of late paul than he was early
well i think you peeked on my scouting
report michael he is getting better the
last three starts pitching to a 1.20
era his first first four starts he was
at 8.82 he has a big curveball he has
always had a big curveball throws it 42
percent of the time hitters only hitting
170 off of it this year and oldie but
goody he now since albert pool halls has
been released
is the oldest player in the major
leagues
and a soft liner and a little leap for
lau and a catch out there at second
so le mayhew is out number one now here
is giancarlo he's at 283 nine homers and
24 rbis
that one is ripped to left field it's a
base hit cutting over is a rosarina
and stanton gets to first with a single
high fly ball
right field
and margot is there to make the catch
so two outs runner at first and here's
geo rochelle and he's been as toughing
out as anybody in this lineup now the o2
pitch on its way swinging a ground ball
toward third backhanded by bronzo his
throw in a second is going to be in time
to take care of stan as he goes the
short road it's a fielder's choice and
now that deal with jameson taion this
will be a seven start one and two 5.02
well keep it going i mean the starters
have been phenomenal we have gone over
you know 22 out of 23 straight well ty
owns coming off a good outing also six
in the third three hits three runs five
five k's
and that was against the nats on friday
and take it on the road has not had a
good road outing yet at home 1-0 with
the 3.00 era so 1-0 on a rosarina
that's popped up shallow left center
clint frazier makes the catch and here's
austin meadows
swing and a miss meadow's down on
strikes manuel margot is aboard the 1-1
pitch swinging a rocket toward right
judge moving to his left can't get it
it's going to one-hop the wall he has to
go get it near the wall here's margot
iii and at the last moment he gets a
stop sign as loud pulls in the second
with a double and the rays have second
and third with two outs here in the
first well linares had that windmill
going down there at third base and at
the last moment
put up the stop sign so second and third
with two outs and here we go runner and
scoring position for yandi diaz
now a line driving a base head up the
middle
diaz will drive home both runs yandy
diaz with a face hit the center of the
raised lead two to nothing keep the ice
cream coming we'll take a buffet of it
up here three straight two out hits a
curveball a hanger boy diaz recognizes
it and punishes it right back through
the middle of the field what else is new
so the reigns with a couple runs in the
first three and two so can't he strike
out the side he struck out the first two
and the pitch is cut out of misty struck
out the side shows a very good live
fastball so
one two three on three strikeouts five
strikeouts now for tyrone
gardner earns a lead-off walk and that
is not what hill was looking to do
a little tapper to third
only plays to first
out there
that's a nice play by brossell on that
little tapper down the third base side
such a big swing by lamehu it took him a
little while to get out of the box and
that helped he was able to get straight
towards home plate that gives him a
little bit easier of an angle on the
throw not like anything about that play
was easy hill's toughest inning
this season is the third inning muddling
his way through it but still has a
two-nothing lead can make one more big
pitch
to get out of it a one-two delivery
cocked in the air that should do it into
shallow right field and walmart go in
and to his left moving to hassan down
back to his right makes the catch and
the yankees are turned away rich hill so
a rose arena at first and here is left
hand hitting austin meadows one ball one
strike here to meadows
and the pitch lifted to the air towards
right hit pretty deep judge looking up
on the wall gone
a two-round homer for austin meadows the
rays have a four-nothing lead meadow's
eighth home run of the year well this is
exactly what the rays want to do get a
lead and add to it mislocation that ends
up down and in in austin meadows after
seeing all of those pitches in his first
at-bat he does not miss that one the
rays have a pretty sizable lead there's
a little bit of an uneven start out of
the out of the gate there for for rich
hill but he has really calmed things
down he's gotten into a good rhythm with
his sequencing and what he feels
comfortable with and a lot of strikes
in a way man to miss
gardner out number one here it's like
swinging a fly swap you're just trying
to just swat it the release point the
arm angle the spin the break cannot be
comfortable
giancarlo stanton and a cut to miz he
dropped down 67 miles per hour right
there as he strikes out the side here in
the fifth hill is starting to put
something together here over the last
few outings yeah i mean how about it 16
consecutive scoreless innings
and the pitch
that one is ripped to left field it's a
base hit it gets past the rosarina and
goes to the wall judge is going for two
and he'll make it a lead off double for
aaron judge he has had some really good
at bets first and third one out mike
ford is at the plate the 1-0 swinging a
ground ball on one hop the window he's
racing the second out throw to first in
the dirt double play
double play what a pick by yandi and the
rays turd two and deny the yankees here
in the sixth it goes six to three and
it's still four-nothing rays so after
first and second nobody out it's now
first and second two outs it will be
after randy rosarina
that's a drive deep to laugh with carrie
and gone
homerun rosarina
a three-run blast it's 7-0
randy a rosarenda has just hit his
fourth home run of the year at three
runs
what a job tonight by rich hill six and
two thirds shutout innings season's high
104 pitches for hill and nine strikeouts
three walks three hits no runs his
impressive run that he is on potential
for some fireworks here gotta come over
the plate we're just walking in run
and that's going to drop in there for a
base hit
up the right field line
two runs have scored and the second goes
meadows
stopping at third for rose harena now
smith and bronzo score the yankees are
down to their final out
one two sky to left
rosarina
waiting and he makes the catch and the
raids win this one
it's a 9-1-1 final